remember Finding Nemo the movie that
introduced us to clownfish dory the
absent-minded sidekick now has her own
movie but marine conservationists
they're not excited they're actually
kind of worried this right here is a
blue tang the real-life dory
they only live on coral reefs in the
South Pacific but before we get to her
story let's talk about Nemo the
clownfish when Finding Nemo came out
well okay I'll let Karen tell you I'm
Karen Burke da Silva I'm a marine
biologist and a conservation biologists
here at Flinders University of South
Australia so what happened with Finding
Nemo after the release of Finding Nemo
we found that there was quite a big
increase in the number of people that
wanted a clownfish as a pet with the
increase in demand it did have an
increase in captive breeding but it also
meant that more fish were being taken
from the wild and in fact some places
there's been so much over collecting
that clownfish have gone locally extinct
oh so captive breeding seems like the
way to go back to Dory the blue tang if
her movie has the same effect as Nemo's
moviegoers are sure to want to buy a
blue tang of their own but there's a
problem
and you are my name is Matt de Maggio
I'm a assistant professor at the
University of Florida tropical
aquaculture laboratory okay Matt so
what's the problem
clownfish are relatively easy to raise
in captivity but up until now no one has
raised blue tags in captivity blue tang
larvae are inherently difficult to raise
they have a very small mouth when they
hatch out so the food particles that we
have to offer them are much smaller and
much more difficult to raise the best
success we've had to date is using a Zoe
plankton called a copepod
the copepods that we grow here only eat
live microalgae so you not have to
live microalgae to feed to the coma bugs
basically raising blue tang so far is
really really hard which means a hundred
percent of blue tang are currently being
taken from the wild for the aquarium
trade most collectors in Australia will
use very careful collecting measures in
other parts of the world Southeast Asia
they are using cyanide still to collect
aquarium fish that's not good but
there's hope Matt and his team are
working hard to breeding successfully
there's only one other tank species the
yellow tang that's ever been raised in
captivity before we're hoping that the
blue tang will be the second alright so
until they do when little Johnny says he
wants a Dory
perhaps the better choice for now at
least is to stick to the blue betta or a
goldfish